[Aplausos]
[Música]
vladimir putin es como tu jefe no te cae
bien no te fías él pero le necesitas
para poder pagar el alquiler hacía
tiempo que no hablábamos de russian
visual político y creo que ya sé lo que
estáis pensando
[Música]
otra vez fonseca otra vez nos vas a
hablar de petróleo pues no esta vez
vamos a hablar de gas natural muchos
pensaréis que son temas muy parecidos a
fin de cuentas normalmente los países
que tienen reservas de petróleo también
suelen tener reservas de gas natural
pero hay una sutil diferencia el
petróleo está mucho más diversificado
por ejemplo rusia suministra el 30 por
ciento del petróleo que llega a europa
pero tenemos una larguísima lista de
otros productores que nos venden su zumo
de dinosaurios
en el caso del gas natural hablamos de
muchos menos productores y en este caso
rusia supone un 40% y en algunos países
la dependencia es aún mayor por ejemplo
alemania depende en un 60 por ciento del
gas ruso y otros países como finlandia o
los bálticos dependen en un cien por
cien de rusia en otras palabras que si
putin quisiera podría dejar a todos
estos países en mitad de un frío
invierno que haría que juego de tronos
pareciera a los vigilantes de la playa
pero esperad un momento porque no sólo
hablamos de calefacción en realidad el
consumo de los hogares es sólo una
tercera parte del total
[Música]
como podéis ver en esta gráfica el otro
tercio el de la franja azul se destina a
la producción de electricidad en las
centrales de ciclo combinado pero el
grueso de la demanda de gas corresponde
a las empresas por ejemplo una fábrica
de papel necesita por un lado energía
eléctrica pero también necesita energía
térmica es decir calor y para obtener
ese calor la fábrica utiliza gas y lo
mismo ocurre con un montón de industrias
más en otras palabras el gas es esencial
para europa y el gas barato es esencial
para que las empresas de europa sean
competitivas y quién es el principal
consumidor de gas de toda europa
exacto alemania el país con más
población pero sobre todo con más
industria de todo el continente y aquí
es donde está la clave de la historia
porque mientras alemania dependa de
rusia toda europa dependerá de rusia
también y por eso en la cumbre de la
otan de 2018
donald trump decía cosas
como esta alemania está totalmente
controlada por rusia porque van a sacar
entre un 60 y un 70 por ciento del gas
en el nuevo gasoducto es decir que es
apropiado pero yo creo que no y creo que
es malo para la otan así que la pregunta
es tiene razón trump en criticar a
alemania de verdad es un problema que
europa dependa tanto del gas ruso es más
de verdad hay algún intento serio para
reducir esta dependencia hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
nuestro hombre en berlín hay dos formas
de transportar el gas la más barata es a
través del gasoducto
[Música]
es decir construimos una tubería
gigantesca que va desde el sitio donde
se saca por ejemplo el yacimiento de
jamal en rusia hasta el país que lo
compra es un sistema muy barato porque
basta con construir la tubería y ya está
no hacen falta ni camiones ni barcos ni
nada parecido según sale el gas llega a
las casas ya las fábricas apenas hace
falta procesarlo pero hay otro método
alternativo el llamado gas natural
licuado también conocido por sus siglas
[Música]
y cómo funciona este método pues bien
imaginad que sacamos el gas de un
yacimiento por ejemplo en qatar cuando
sacamos el gas lo enfriamos hasta llegar
a menos 161 grados centígrados a estas
temperaturas el gas se convierte en
líquido que podemos guardar en
botellitas estas botellitas las metemos
en un barco metanero que llega por
ejemplo al puerto de barcelona en españa
[Música]
barcelona- hay una planta regasificadora
que vuelve a calentar el líquido para
convertirlo en gas es de gas por fin se
enchufa a la red y llega a fábricas y
hogares cuál es la ventaja de este
proceso que permitiría que europa
pudiera recibir gas de muchos otros
sitios y cuál es el problema pues que es
entre un 50 y un 70% más caro que el gas
que viene por los gasoductos y eso
explica que los países europeos compren
gas a los productores que tienen más
cerca con los que están conectados por
tuberías
[Música]
por ejemplo el principal suministrador
de españa es argelia sin embargo los
países del norte de europa compran a
noruega y sobre todo a rusia
[Música]
como decíamos antes empresas rusas como
rosneft lukoil venden más de la mitad
del gas que se consume en alemania y qué
pasa en los países que están entre
alemania y rusia pues que tienen una
relación de dependencia aún más profunda
fijaos en este mapa
[Música]
si os fijáis veréis que algunos países
como polonia dependen en un 75% del gas
ruso
otros como finlandia o rumanía llegan al
100% en otras palabras que media europa
necesita a rusia para sobrevivir y esto
no es ningún secreto la comisión europea
lo sabe rusia lo sabe putin también lo
sabe incluso él lo sabe
alemania se volverá totalmente
dependiente de la energía rusa si no
cambia de rumbo de inmediato course
quieren the west aquí en occidente
estamos comprometidos a mantener nuestra
independencia frente a la invasión de
las potencias extranjeras expansionistas
vamos a pausar el vídeo un momento justo
aquí donde vemos a la delegación alemana
en las naciones unidas- riéndose de
trump fijaos que donald trump dice que
alemania se va a volver dependiente de
la energía rusa es decir si ya es
dependiente lo va a ser aún más pero a
qué se refiere exactamente vamos a
rebobinar un minuto
[Aplausos]
[Música]
quedaos con este nombre gerhard
schroeder seguro que muchos ya lo
conocéis se trata de el ex canciller
alemán es decir el predecesor de angela
merkel un hombre que todavía mantiene
una enorme influencia en la política
alemana y europea y a qué se dedica el
señor schroeder ahora mismo pues nada
más y nada menos que a construir esto
[Música]
el expresidente de la otan rasmussen
dice que alemania entra en la trampa de
putin con el norte estrictos
básicamente el nord stream 2 es un nuevo
gasoducto que pasaría por debajo del mar
báltico
con esta nueva tubería alemania
duplicaría sus compras de gas ruso este
nuevo gasoducto tiene un comité de
accionistas donde hay varias empresas
entre otras la rusa gazprom y el
presidente de este comité de accionistas
es nada más y nada menos que el señor
weather por si esto fuera poco el ex
canciller alemán es también el
presidente de rosneft una empresa
petrolera rusia
[Música]
esto explica que en los últimos 10 años
redes se haya convertido en algo así
como el hombre de putin en europa de
hecho ha salido en defensa de rusia en
toda clase de asuntos desde los
ciberataques a estonia hasta la
ocupación de crimea en otras palabras
que lejos de reducir su independencia de
rusia alemania da pasos en la dirección
opuesta
así que de que se estaban riendo a los
alemanes pues la verdad es que no lo sé
pero ya me puedo imaginar lo que
estaréis pensando muchos y cuál es el
problema con depender de rusia de putin
es un líder autoritario en serio en
serio ese es el problema casi mejor no
miremos al resto de proveedores a
azerbaiyán argelia qatar
vamos que todos ellos son países
gobernados por hermanitas de la caridad
precisamente pues no no se trata de
democracia ni de derechos humanos
el problema con depender de rusia es
otro ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
la ruso dependencia en el año 2006 la
rusa gazprom quiso multiplicar por seis
el precio del gas para ucrania
la cuestión venía de antes ucrania
mantenía una relación bastante amistosa
con rusia hasta la revolución naranja os
acordáis de las disputas entre víctor
yanukóvich y víctor yúschenko pues
cuando víctor yúschenko llegó al poder
con un discurso anti ruso y más por
europeo desde el kremlin empezaron a
pensar a
con que esas tenemos ucrania pues ya
puedes ir preparando la cuenta corriente
porque esto no te va a salir barato
pensadlo bien construir un gasoducto
lleva años así que ucrania no podía
buscar nuevos proveedores de la noche a
la mañana si putin quería podía subir el
precio lo que le daba la gana y qué
pasaba si ucrania se negaba a pagarlo
pues muy fácil rusia cortaba el grifo
durante tres días en plena ola de frío
los ucranianos se quedaron sin
calefacción
y el caso se cerró con que gran ya
aceptó pagar el doble de lo que venía
pagando hasta el momento a cambio subió
el peaje que le cobraba a rusia por
cruzar con sus gasoductos el territorio
ucraniano hacia europa pero esto es sólo
el principio
en el año 2009 tuvimos el mismo problema
pero a lo bestia rusia quería que
ucrania pagará más por el gas y en moscú
se enzarzaron en una ensalada de
insultos y en este caso no sólo ucrania
se quedó sin gas sino también el resto
de europa desde república checa- hasta
italia pasando por polonia y por
supuesto a alemania nuevamente la
historia se cerró con que ucrania pagaba
aún más por el gas ruso pero a la vez
cobrarían más como peaje por usar su
territorio para llegar al resto de
europa sin embargo como pasa en juego de
tronos la canción de putin es de hielo y
fuego así que tras dejar sin calefacción
a millones de europeos en 2006 y 2009 en
el turno del fuego
[Música]
el fuego se lo llevó una provincia
ucraniana que se llama crimea como ya
sabéis rusia invadió y se quedó con
crimen y si no lo sabéis lo podéis ver
en este otro vídeo y que hizo la unión
europea en este caso pues básicamente le
dijeron a rusia putin eres un chico muy
malo te vamos a poner unas sanciones y
nos vas a escribir 20 veces no invadir
otros países y más o menos ahí se quedó
la cosa
ucrania es poco más o menos que un dolor
de cabeza tanto para europa como para
rusia y por eso tenemos dos opciones la
favorita de putin y de reder es
construir un nuevo gasoducto que sortea
ucrania muerto el perro se acabó la
rabia la segunda es la favorita de jean
claude juncker y la unión europea buscar
otros productores de gas pero de verdad
es eso viable pues ahora mismo lo vamos
a ver
[Música]
intentos de diversificación la opción
más rápida sería comprar gas natural
licuado es caro sí pero no hay que
esperar a construir nuevas tuberías el
problema que los barcos metaneros están
demasiado ocupados suministrando a asia
básicamente todo el océano pacifico está
lleno de barcos metaneros que van desde
australia a catar y malasia para
abastecer a japón china y korea la razón
que en estos países se paga mucho más
por el gas
[Música]
así que países como qatar o incluso eeuu
que serían potenciales suministradores
de gas licuado prefieren mirar a asia
que a europa y por eso la alternativa
más factible pero a la vez más
complicada es la de construir nuevos
gasoductos y la pregunta es
por un lado tenemos noruega pero europa
ya consume todo el gas que produce este
país si miramos más al sur españa ha
insistido durante años en construir el
llamado midcat un gasoducto con
capacidad para transportar europa el gas
que llega desde argelia
sin embargo francia no está por la labor
porque tendrían que ser ellos los que
construirían la red para distribuirlo
por el resto de europa
menuda aliada mañana en medio quedan
[Música]
la próxima semana tengo movida y eso ya
ya si eso ya está
así que por el momento el proyecto más
serio es el llamado gasoducto
transadriático tap que se terminará de
construir en 2020
[Música]
esta tubería parte de los impresionantes
yacimientos de shah deniz en azerbayán
para cruzar turquía hasta llegar a
italia pero esperad un momento porque
esto no es suficiente esta tubería
podría transportar un máximo de 20 mil
millones de metros cúbicos de gas esto
no es ni la mitad de lo que llegaría a
través del nord stream 2 que quiere
construir rusia y alemania- pero esperad
un momento porque este no es el único
problema por si pensabais que al kremlin
no le importaba este intento de
promiscuidad gasística estáis muy pero
que muy equivocados
gazprom asegura que el tránsito de gas a
través de ucrania a europa puede caer de
10 a 15 bcm por año
con este movimiento putty mata dos
pájaros de un tiro por un lado aprieta
las tuercas a europa por el otro
consigue sortear a ucrania pero aquí no
se queda la cosa en el sur
putin también está presionando para
crear nuevas tuberías y si pensabais que
schroeder es el único amigo de putin en
europa
estabais muy pero que muy equivocados
[Música]
hungría quiere que el gasoducto to
extremes se extienda a europa en las
próximas semanas vamos a cubrir dos
flecos que quedan en esta historia por
un lado tenemos que hablar de ucrania
hasta qué punto putin puede prescindir
de ucrania por el otro tenemos que
hablar de azerbaiyán una dictadura con
la que tal vez nos tengamos que empezar
a llevar bien pero de todo eso
hablaremos las próximas semanas así que
ya sabéis suscribiros a visual político
y darle a la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones
mientras tanto la pregunta es para
vosotros de verdad quién europa a
reducir su dependencia de rusia o veis a
putin como rey de la noche con capacidad
de convertir a todos los europeos en
caminantes blancos
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y también en esta encuesta y
por supuesto no olvidéis visitar nuestra
página de patrián donde podréis formar
parte activa de esta comunidad y además
podréis apoyar este proyecto
si os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like
y nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto